I wanted first to just, uh, think
back a little bit about, uh,
the lecture we got from Steve
Schwarzman and a Friday, uh,
before he came, I talk
with them in my office. Uh,
and I had the audacity to ask him if he
thought there was any chance that his
fortune was just due
to luck. I said, well,
we have this efficient markets
theory, uh, in finance, uh,
that, uh, uh,
says that nobody can beat the market.
So what do you think he said?
Um, obviously he believes
in himself, but I,
I'm inclined to believe in him also,
uh,
that efficient markets
theory never sounded right.
Uh,
what one thing about efficient market
theory that has always bothered me is this
idea that the so called smart
money sets prices in the market.
Um, the thing that bothers me about
it is who is the smart money anyway?
It's as if it's an all or nothing thing,
right?
There's the smart money and then as the
dumb money and the smart money rules,
but isn't there all different
gradations of intelligence and insight?
So it's not like why should they
be just one level of smart money?
So I think he probably exemplifies,
uh,
a higher level of smart money
than smart. I think a lot of, um,
mistakes people make in judging financial
markets is a being easily impressed by
someone stockbroker or
someone's analyst who, uh,
who seems very smart and is very smart
but may not be enough to outsmart the
markets. Uh, so that's the
lesson of efficiency. Uh,
especially when you're young.
I think you may not realize how many
smart people there are in the world.
And, uh, uh, and so when you,
when you're dealing in a trying
to win and financial markets,
you have to take account of who out,
who is really out there and how much
insight and effort and research are they
putting in to their trading.
And you really think you can beat that.
Uh,
so that's the lesson of efficient market.
But I don't think the lesson is
that you can't, uh, you can't.
It's impossible for anyone no matter how
smart to beat the market. Now, of course,
you know, Albert Einstein never made any
money in the stock market. And in fact,
Tia Cref,
the pension fund had an ad campaign
in which they pointed out that Albert
Einstein left all of his pension
investing to Tia Cref. He was a professor.
And, uh, there are a pension
fund for professors. So, uh,
Einstein didn't think he could
beat the market. And, uh,
Mr Schwartzman very candidly pointed out
that he didn't have the greatest a math
score. Isn't that one how he fought
it? He said he was no math genius.
And you think finance requires a
lot of math. Um, but I think that,
you know, it's uh, uh,
it's something about
practical intelligence. Uh,
psychologists have talked about
different kinds of intelligence. Uh,
this thing is all supposed
to be coming up here. Uh,
at least we're seeing something now.
Uh,
that's why I don't like a PowerPoint.
Actually. This kind of thing happens.
Uh,
yeah,
so, uh, that's it. Uh, and now,
yeah.
Okay. Uh, so, uh,
I'm not going to use
this for a few minutes,
so I'll just blink it out for the moment.
Um,
but you know, remember Carl Icahn when he
talked to us, said something about, um,
he always just had some, he was always
just good at making money, I think.
And I think that, um, uh,
there are separate talents.
I mean some people love markets and I
like to think about them and figure out
how they work and,
um,
if they have the right kind
of intelligence and the
right kind of spirit to do
the work,
they ought to be able to beat the market.
When I've talked to icon a number of
times and I have the idea that he's a very
down to earth, solid, inquisitive
sort, he wants to know what's going on.
Uh, and when I've talked to him, sometimes
he'll ask the same question of me.
He's trying to get information from me.
It asks the same question from me three
different ways because apparently my
answer isn't satisfactory and he must
think I might know something cause he
keeps asking.
I think that's the kind of persistence.
It's certain personality traits.
So persistence that trying to figure
out what really makes things work, um,
is, uh, is important in
these, in these markets.
And I think it's just relish or
inclination to keep thinking about them.
So maybe that's why I went
into economics as a professor.
I don't know that I really,
and someone who wants to watch the markets
all day and so you have to judge your
own, uh, interest. Uh, so anyway,
it was very nice that we got, um, uh,
Steve Schwarzman came and
told us about his life's work.
Uh,
so anyway, I, I wanted to
talk today about futures. Uh,
oh,
but one more thing I wanted to say about
a Schwarzman I was dating at one point,
he said very confidently, uh, I
thought now if you've heard this right,
that this current financial crisis
ought to be over in a year, and that,
uh, he said something and it was
a little vague about, about, uh,
investing in distressed securities
now as an opportunity because,
uh, I think he pointed out
that AAA mortgage securities
are selling for 80 some
cents on the dollar and
it can't be that bad.
And now this is the same thing that we
got from David Swensen and I've heard it
from others that that's the
opportunity now. So when,
when I hear Steve Schwarzman
proclaiming that he thinks this,
I thought he said something like
that, that this, uh, business, uh,
crisis will be over before Laura.
It made me wonder, you know,
do I do I know more than he does about
that sort of thing cause I don't think
it's going to be over.
So then it gets back to,
I think you have to put all
these people in perspective.
There's so many different
kinds of expertise. Um,
and when you listen to someone,
you always have to ask, well,
what does he or she know that,
uh,
that is specific to their expertise?
And I don't think Schwartzman
is a macro economist. So, uh,
I don't want to say he's wrong,
but he might be wrong. Really.
Let's not put everyone you're good
thing is to listen to everyone. And uh,
and not,
uh,
except that anyone has
the whole truth anywhere.
Um,
I wanted to get onto futures markets
and so that is a very important topic.
Uh,
in finance.
And the important thing to understand
when I put an s on the end futures that
refers to a marketplace with
a particular characteristic,
uh, and, uh, as, as traded
on a number of exchanges,
notably in the u s the biggest exchange
for futures is the Chicago Mercantile
Exchange, which just merge with
the Chicago Board of trade.
Uh,
and they are now called the c
the group.
Uh,
so future a sense,
it has its origin in agriculture is a
Chicago thing rather than a New York
thing. Chicago is the second city,
or it was the second biggest city,
um, hog butcher to the world, farmers,
a marketplace in the Midwest.
Uh,
and so future is in the United
States. Started there, uh,
and uh,
but actually future is,
didn't start in Chicago.
Um,
it started in Japan,
uh,
on an island,
in Osaka called Dejima.
Um, and, uh,
in the 16 hundreds in the,
uh, sorry, I didn't, yeah,
it was a 1600 1673 is the date
date for the first futures market.
And so I was just in Osaka
again a few months ago. Uh,
and I again asked, can
I please see Dejima, uh,
because it's such a historic
place, uh, and again,
they said there's nothing to see there.
It's all,
anything from long ago it was gone.
Uh,
but that was where these markets started.
So let's go back and I'm not sure
how well developed it was in 1673,
but let's say early 17 hundreds in dodgy.
My,
what was happening? Well, it was
the Ryse Center for Japan. Uh,
their people,
rice merchants would bring
their rice too though Gima and,
uh, sell them there. And, uh, also, uh,
naturally as you would expect, there
were big warehouses for rice, uh,
which, uh, which store it, uh, would
be a natural thing to see at the,
uh, at the, uh, center of trade. Uh, and,
uh, it was a big thriving
trade center. Uh,
so people, when they buy it, incidentally,
let's talk about the fundamental problem.
Uh,
agricultural commodities like rice
are harvested typically once a year.
Actually, I think rice has
more than one harvest. Um,
but let's, uh, let's just simplify it.
I say it's harvested once per year and
people depend on it for their lives
actually because they need the food
for, uh, for the, for the whole year.
So that means there's a storage business.
Rice has to be stored,
you have to keep it away from moisture
and rot and away from rats and vermins.
And that's a business and it's a
very important business or any,
uh, any country. If it isn't rice,
it would be some other grain
which is stored. And so,
uh,
when people buy and sell grain,
they know it's their thinking out at
least a year because that's how long the
cycle is for one, one
harvest, one, uh, one cycle.
And so lots of contracts are
signed to buy and sell rice,
but typically at some future date. So, uh,
well we talk about spot contracts,
uh,
means buying and selling
something right now.
So if you show up at the warehouse
and say, I've got my wagons,
I want to load rice in a,
how much do I have to pay to get rice?
That price would be called the
spot price on the spot right now.
Uh,
but often you would show up at
the warehouse and you would say,
you know, I have some trucks, wagons
coming next week or next month.
And I want to arrange now
to, uh, to buy the rice. Uh,
and uh,
if you say,
if you agree on a price today
for delivery in one month,
that's called a forward contract.
Okay.
Not Futures. There's an important
distinction between forward and futures.
A forward contract.
Let me explain what a forward contract.
It's very simple.
It's a contract between two parties to
exchange something at a future date for a
price in the future that's
pre determined today.
So for example, a forward
contract will be, uh, between me,
a rice merchant and the warehouse that
in two months I will come and take
delivery of,
you know,
so many bushels of rice and then
I will pay such and such a price.
Okay. That's a forward
contract. So before 1673,
there were lots of forward
contracts and lots of, uh,
people trading in these. And
so someone in Doji, my thought,
why don't we set up a big
market for these? Because, uh,
people have trouble knowing what
the price is for a forward contract.
People would travel around from one
warehouse to another and they get a
different price from one or the other,
and they kind of wonder what the price is,
you know, today. So someone said, well,
why don't we kind of create a
market for forward contracts? Uh,
but we don't call them forward contract.
I don't know what they call them in
Japan and I'm just going to get the idea.
So the idea is let's create a marketplace,
a central marketplace so
that all of these different,
you don't have to go around in
a hundred different warehouses.
They try to find the best price. You
find out what the real price is. Uh,
and so what they did is they
created an exchange in Doe Jima.
Uh, and the exchange had
a lot of modern features.
It had a trading floor.
Okay.
There was a designated area where people
who wanted to trade in rice futures
would congregate.
Uh,
and all trades we're
supposed to be done there.
So that became a central
marketplace. Um, and uh,
so many people came to the exchange floor
that it got very noisy and traders can
be very noisy people shouting
and getting upset, uh,
trading rapidly back and forth.
So in they developed in Doji
Ma instead of hand signals.
So it was so noisy and loud that you
couldn't talk sometimes and it was hard,
especially to communicate something to
someone on the other side of the room.
So they invented hand signals.
So the traders would be,
I don't know exactly what they were,
but typically when you,
if you had something like this,
you hold out your hand with your palm out.
That means I want to sell. And if it's
four fingers up, that means for contracts,
if you put it this way, uh, it would
be buying, I want to buy for contracts.
So those hand signals developed in,
in Osaka and they became a mainstay
of futures markets after that.
Okay. So, uh,
another thing they did in Japan
to create the central market, uh,
was to standardize the rice.
So, uh, standardized.
Now, uh, this is very important.
If you go shopping around to different
warehouses to try to buy rice,
you'll get some warehouse
who says, well, I'm charged.
I know I'm charging a higher price,
but my rice is better than that
other guy's rice. You know,
his has some worms in it, sometimes
don't trust that other guy. Uh,
and so, or whatever it is, or you know,
even rice isn't all the same, right?
There's different varieties and some
of them taste better than others. Uh,
so how would you ever know what the
price of rice? It's just a mess.
So what they did in Osaka is they made
a standard form of rice for delivery in
their contract. Okay?
That's important because,
uh,
there's many kinds of rights,
but they picked one that's
maybe the most common. Uh,
and then they said that's what
all of our contracts are about.
So you would be taking delivery
of a standard rice. Moreover,
at the exchange they had experts on
rice who could tell whether it was that
contract.
It's not the best rice,
it's the most common rice.
I visited the coffee sugar and cocoa
exchange in New York once and jokingly I
said, can I have a cup of coffee?
And so this is the coffee,
sugar and cocoa exchange.
Surely I can get a cup of coffee here.
And then the guy said, uh, who was
showing me around, he said, well,
we could give you a cup of coffee, but
it's not what we trade here. Uh, he says,
you wouldn't like the coffee we
trade here. It's not Starbucks. Uh,
it's the most standard. So they set up a
standard for coffee at the coffee shop.
Maybe he was being too candid.
I don't know if they would
say that officially they
set up a standard for coffee
at the coffee,
sugar coco exchange and then no one would
ever deliver better coffee than that.
Right. Well, after explain that everyone,
they wouldn't even be allowed to.
The whole idea is the
contract has standards.
Uh, what, what actually
happens if you are,
have a contract to deliver rice
or coffee or anything like that.
And there's some expert there who's
going to judge whether what you delivered
was up to quality standards.
And you are a smart businessperson,
you will deliver exactly
the minimum quality,
right to fulfill the contract.
So it'll never be below the minimum
quality because no one can deliver it.
The x,
the testers will not allow that.
And it can't be above the minimum
standard because you'd never do that.
You'd be stupid to do that.
So you always,
it's always becomes the standard variety.
So what they did at the futures market
is they then not only had standardized
the rice,
but they standardized delivery date
and delivery locations.
So they then, so what, what,
what would you trade on these
con in these futures markets?
You would be training,
you either be buying or selling rice
for future delivery on a standardized
delivery date at a standardized location,
probably one of the warehouses
that they designate. Okay.
Um,
and that might not be the rice
you want or the date you want.
And yet somehow the market
gets going and gets very big.
And this is the reason the,
what a futures market does
that's different from a
warehouse market is it sets
up a standard price and a liquid market.
And the,
uh,
and so people end up using the futures
market to lock in the price or to,
or to hedge price risk.
And they,
they know that the price in the
futures market is the meaningful price.
You hear all kinds of prices of rice.
You know,
you ever hear rumors here and there,
uh, they'll, someone will say,
I saw a rice sell for such and such,
so many Yan or whatever it is.
Don't believe any of that nonsense.
Who knows what was sold
or what terms there were,
what exigencies there were only look at
the futures market because the future's
market is absolutely standardized,
you know, the terms of delivery,
the location and everything else.
And so what ended up happening is that
everyone wanted to trade in the futures
market and it became a huge market.
Uh,
and then everyone started
watching the futures price. Okay.
So, uh, that's, that's
what we now have wood.
That's what is in a future.
I wanted to taste some other,
one other curious thing about the two
other things about the Osaka market is
they had trading hours
just as we do today. Uh,
in other words,
only certain hours of the day the floor
was open and then it was shut off.
And so people get very excited
and trade very actively.
You have to somehow let people know that
the trading time is over and all trades
have to stop at the end of the day.
So they had a burning fuse,
which they would light in the middle
of the trading floor just a few minutes
before the end of the day.
And you can see this flame and that
meant you better finish your trades right
now because when the flame
goes out, it's over. Uh,
and so we don't have fuses anymore.
We have clock the same and a bell at
announces the beginning and end at an
exchange. Uh, but there's
one of the thing they had,
which I think is kind of curious,
but it hasn't been copied.
They had people called water
men who after the fuse went out,
they carried buckets of
water under the exchange.
And if anybody was still trading,
they splashed them with water.
That was the doubts that the fuses out.
Everything is Dallas for today. Uh,
we don't do that in modern
futures exchanges. Of course,
it's all electronic now.
There's no, well, it's getting
increasingly electronic.
The CME and the CVOT still have trading
floors like Doji Mazu and they're still
using these hand signals. Uh, but it's,
it's getting lonely there because
everything is moving away,
uh, to the, um, uh,
everything is moving away
to the electronic markets.
But you'll still see on CNBC, uh, Bob
[inaudible], we'll be standing at the, uh,
t bond trading pit, uh,
and he'll give us little,
they focus the camera right on where all
the people are active and they're still
out there. Josh jostling
each other and, um,
shouting at each other.
Uh, so it's still going on,
but it's increasingly becoming
an electronic market. Um,
but I guess the, uh, uh,
the most important thing to realize
about futures markets is that they're
different from forward markets in that it,
uh,
with a futures market,
when you buy and sell a contract,
you are buying and selling with the
exchange or the clearinghouse of the
exchange.
And you do not know the counterparty.
You do not know who's on the other side.
With a forward market,
you
with a forward market,
you know very well who's
on the other side, you're,
you're going into a
warehouse and there was,
this warehouse is going to
take your w, your grain, uh,
and uh, in the warehouse, uh,
you better trust the other side because
suppose the other side doesn't work.
And I suppose you have your,
you've loaded up all your rice and you
come to the warehouse and then the guy
says, uh, oh, I don't, I don't, I don't
want to honor the contract. I signed it,
but I just not going to take it or
I'm going to lower the price on you.
Then you have to sue this guy, you
know, and it's a big mess. So, uh,
the problem with forward contracts
is that they're not standardized.
You're not dealing with a reputable
exchange with an exchange.
There is of course,
the counterparty,
if you're selling rice and
someone else is buying it,
but there's an intermediary between
you and that's the exchange.
And since the exchange,
we'll honor any contract,
you don't have to worry
about the other side.
So that's another reason why futures,
price prices,
there's so much more meaningful
than spot or forward prices, uh,
because there's no, uh,
uh, put it this way,
there's no counterparty risk
unless you worry about
the exchange itself.
But since the feature exchanges in the
u s had been here since the 19th century
and they've never lost a contract,
people assume as a first approximation
a that there is no counterparty risk.
Um,
but before I,
I'm still haven't maybe fully explained
futures, but let me, uh, before we go on,
I wanted to talk a little bit about
forwards, uh, because we then,
now we have a slide up here.
We do have forward contracts and they
still play an important function.
The reason is that futures markets by
their very nature are standardized markets
or you might say their retail markets,
they have a huge number of people trading
in them, but it's all a standard thing.
Forward markets are,
are between persons. Uh,
and so they, they can be, the
contract can be anything you want.
And so forward contracts
are very important. Uh,
but they tend to be less. Uh, well, I,
I tend to observe them last because
they don't have this newsworthy
characteristic.
Everyone's talking about futures prices
because everyone knows that is a very
well defined central market,
liquid price.
The forward contracts are not liquid.
You can't get out of it. So if you
as a rice merchant sold your rice,
if you are, say a rice farmer, you sold
your rice forward to, uh, uh, to, uh,
uh, to a warehouse, uh, and
then you change your mind.
You want to get out. Uh, you can't
because unless the other guy says,
I'll let you out because you've
just got a contract. And so, uh,
the futures has this
active trading in and out.
And so the prices seem to mean more.
But let's talk about forward market.
There's forward markets for a lot
of things. One very important.
A forward market is a foreign
exchange forward market.
And this happens a lot because
there's tons of businesses that have,
they sell things,
uh,
in countries around the world and
they get a foreign currencies.
So if you sell some Europe manufacturer
and you sell something in, uh,
in Japan, uh, then they're
paying you in yen, uh,
and they might be paying
you in three months.
And so you worry about the exchange
rate between dollars and yen. So, uh,
you want to get it in dollars.
So you might want to find a counterparty
who will exchange your yen for dollars
in three months, uh, or
whatever the term is a.
And so that's called a forward contract
for exchange of currencies. Uh,
very simple. Okay, I'm getting,
I'm selling cars in Japan.
That sounds, that does happen.
US cars sold in Japan. Uh,
and so I'm going to get, I know I'm going
to get this yen in three months. Uh,
I just, uh, sign a contract with
somebody to exchange dollars.
We fixed the exchange rate. That's
called the forward exchange rate. Okay?
It's not necessarily the same as
today's exchange rate. In fact,
it will generally be systematically
different. Uh, and so we have this, uh,
what's called forward interest
parody relation. The forward,
this is an arbitrage relationship that
holds very well in the forward market for
foreign exchange. The forward
exchange rate, that's yen per dollar.
In the case of a, we're
talking about Japan, us, uh,
equals the spot exchange
rate. Uh, that's uh,
in, uh, in, uh,
uh, the yen per dollar times one,
plus the yen interest rate. That's for
three months. If it's three months,
a horizon times one plus the
dollar interest rate. Uh,
and that, that relation
holds very well. Uh,
because if it didn't hold,
I could make money, uh,
quickly, uh, without risk and
uh, that shouldn't happen. Right?
Think of it this way.
The interest rate in Japan is different
from the interest rate in the u s
government bonds issued in Japan
are perfectly safe. Well, I mean,
you could say, of course the
Japanese government could
default, but hey, you know,
it's not going to happen to a first
approximation is not going to call that a
zero probability.
Uh,
and same thing with the u s so how can
two different countries have different
interest rates?
Because you would think what wouldn't
investor is always invest in the country
with the higher interest rate.
Why now? If it's riskless, well,
there is risk and that's
exchange rate risk.
But you can get rid of the risk by taking
a forward contract. So you could say,
if you're living in Japan,
I note that interest rates are higher in
the u s then Japan. So I'm going to go,
I'm not going to invest in yen, uh, bonds.
I'm going to invest in US bonds
and then I'm going to cover myself.
But making a forward contract to
get the money back in the end.
Uh,
well that's a very clear thing to do.
But the problem is you can't make any
money doing it because this holds because
of arbitrary.
There are so many people who've noticed
that that interest rates are higher in
the u s and in Japan.
They're both risk plus interest rates.
It can't be right that there is this
profit opportunity that's riskless.
Uh, and so the forward exchange
rate satisfies this relationship.
The forward rate equals the spot rate
times one. The relative interest rates.
And this is over the horizon between,
now this is not the annual
interest rate unless it's a,
an annual, a forward contract. So if
it's a three month forward contract,
this would be the interest
earned in three months in. Yeah.
And this would be the interest during
the dollars, uh, over three months.
So that's one kind of forward ready
Freeman. This market works very well.
It satisfies this relate we've explained,
we know this market.
It just satisfies the forward
interest parity condition. Um,
so another, um, uh,
another market, uh, Eh,
a forward market is
the market for, uh, uh,
different interest rates. Uh, so, uh, we,
we can have a forward a loan.
We can say I want to make it alone at
a future date of a certain maturity.
Well, let's tie in the
interest rate now. Uh, so our,
as the contract rate,
so suppose you want to either borrow
or lend money in the future. Uh,
we talked about forward rates implicit
in the term structure earlier. Uh,
and you could try to
achieve those forward rates.
As we talked about earlier about
buying and selling government bonds.
But this is another way to do
it, which may be simpler. Uh, uh,
it doesn't involve shorting bonds.
You can just make a contract. So, uh,
uh,
there was a contract rate in the
forward contract and the contract says,
and the contract specifies
the contract rate are,
and the number of days,
uh, in the contract period,
that's how many days hence this contract
will be delivered, will be executed.
And this is this, you can make any
forward rate contract you want,
but this is the most standard
contract got it's between counter.
So you can do whatever you want,
but if you talk with a broker
and you got a standard contract,
you'd probably get this.
Now the purpose of this contract
is to lock in an interest rate.
It's a risk management contract.
And so you don't actually want to
bow and lend from this other person.
You'll arrange that separately,
but you want to protect yourself so that
you know today what interest rate you
can get in the future.
So what they do is they defined some
measure of actual interest, right?
And it could be something like live bar
just mentioned library l I v O r is the
London interbank offered rate.
It's just a an interest rate that's
defined by an agency in London.
They have a website and you can read it.
So it's a well known,
well defined interest rate.
So you could say a three month
lie bar is the interest rate.
90 days in the future d would be 90.
Uh,
and so what the contract specifies,
it also specifies a contract them out
a a and B is actually usually 360 but
sometimes I'll say 365 what? You can write
whatever you want and these contracts,
but this is standard typically 360 days.
And so all it specifies what the contract
says. There's two counter parties,
there's the,
the long and the short.
Somebody is receiving interest and
someone is paying interest. So, uh,
the settlement is this amount from
one side to the other. And this,
this formula actually,
it doesn't appear in for Bozi
in exactly this notation,
but this is in the chapter
on futures market. This, uh,
this equation, although it's
written a little differently,
it's the same equation
appears in for Bozi, uh,
in the chapter on futures
markets. Uh, so what you do,
the standard forward contract says one
counterparty pays the other this amount
and that is equal to the, uh, the, uh,
actual interest rate minus the
contract rate times the number of days,
times the number,
uh,
the contract amount divided
by B times a hundred.
This hundred is here because l and R
are assumed to be measured in hundreds.
So, uh, like percent, 3% is
really pointed over three
times l times B. Okay? This,
this equation might be easier if you
divide both numerator and denominator by
100.
Then you can see all the 100 is doing
is correcting the interest rates from
percent to, to, to, uh,
like from 3% to 0.03. So all
it's doing, all this contract is,
is, is an amount, uh, a, um,
a promise to pay the difference between
the contract rate and the actual
interest rate on that date.
So that effectively allows you,
if you want to say bar with that rape
to lock in the interest rate today,
because I will get an amount of money
from this contract that will offset any
changes in interest rates in
the future. So that's, uh,
that's another example
of a, of a contract. Uh,
but I want to emphasize here
futures not, uh, so where am I?
Let's talk about futures prices. Okay. Uh,
I took this from the old newspaper
extra my old lecture. Um,
this is what used to be in the
Wall Street Journal. Uh, and uh,
this is an example of a futures contract.
I'm going to stick here with
agricultural futures. Uh,
in the next lecture we're going
to talk about financial futures,
but I like to talk about agricultural
futures because it's just really expanding
on the Japan, uh, Osaka
Dorjee my story. Uh,
and it's,
it's so earthy agriculture down to earth.
Uh, I think I like to start
with that because it seems
very simple to understand.
Uh,
and so I want him to explain one contract
and I thought I would emphasize corn.
Uh, and this is as it was laid out, uh,
in 2001 that was seven years ago.
I was giving these lectures seven
years ago when I clipped it out.
That was before,
uh,
I must've covered it earlier in the
semester cause I have marks 15 there and
we're now April 14th,
but we'll just use this just as I,
I'll show you in a second what
you can get today. Newspapers,
just seven years ago,
covered lots more financial data than
they do today because we're moving to the
Internet. Of course they had the internet
in 2001, but we weren't so into it then.
So they still publish this in the
Wall Street Journal as of 2001,
so let me just use this
as an example. Now. Uh,
what is this? This is corn.
That's maids. Okay. Uh,
it was what this means that one contract
is a contract to deliver 5,000 bushels.
And the price here is shown
in cents per Bushel. Okay.
And these are the contracts. There
was a, now this is [inaudible].
Today is March 15,
2001,
there's a main contract in
July contract and this is a,
okay, this shows the price
over today, which is March 15,
2001. Okay. The guys
in the pit at the, um,
the stands for Chicago Board of Trade.
I put an o in it,
but often they did say CBT.
There's, uh, there's a,
uh, uh, corn pit okay. With, uh,
with traders and there might be 50 guys.
They're guys and girls.
It's a rough, uh, my colleague
runny wall. And he was, uh,
worked in the futures pits in Chicago.
And uh,
she told me that it was so rough.
She was,
she got pregnant and they were,
she was still coming into work.
Um, and she got knocked over one day by
one of the traders that her boss said,
no way. You have to take a
vacation until the baby is born.
This is no place for a
pregnant woman. Um, it's true.
They get rough and tumble there.
Uh, when I had a tour of the CBOT,
this is like 10 years
ago, I was asking, um,
I was observing the guys in
the pit where, so Rawkus, uh,
and at 1.1 trader got another trader
in a headlock and he was dragging him
around. And, uh,
I think it was all in fun at that time
anyway. But, uh, so the guy said, well,
you know, we had a good record. This,
we've had only two broken arms
this year and that's a good year.
Um, in Chicago, they're not
as, they're farmers, right?
Or I shouldn't be put them down. They're
different. They have a different spirit.
They're not, they're down
to earth, real people that,
and so it's fun to watch,
but it's unfortunately,
it's probably too late unless you
go to the treasury bond pit. Uh,
it's all fading away to under the,
onto the Internet. But anyway,
what this means is these were the prices
that corn took per bushel over that day
of March 15. So if price was going up
and down as they were trading all day,
uh, and so, uh, this
was the opening price.
When the market opened in the morning,
this was the highest price for May
futures. This was the lowest price.
And this is called the settle,
which is essentially the last price,
but not necessarily because the exchange
has a settlement committee and they
decide on what is the last price.
And the reason it's not the same thing
as the last actual trade is that they're
worried about somebody trying
to manipulate the market
and doing something funny
with the last trade. So it's, but
it's, it's like the last trade.
Okay. And so this is the change
from the previous day of the price.
So this is the price for May delivery
at a specified warehouse of corn to
Chicago. Okay. Uh, and, uh,
open interest is the number of contracts.
So there was 186,000 may contract.
That's only two months away.
March,
April,
may you see almost all of the open
interest is in the short contracts.
Okay. Now, if you drive through
the country and turn on the radio,
you will hear at regular intervals,
the announcer will tell you what corn
is doing. So that's a current, uh,
at the latest trading is up
to $2 and 18 cents a Bushel.
What price is that guy coding?
It's always going to be the futures
price. And so you might say, well,
but that's two months in the march, April,
May, why are they talking about May?
Because this is march.
Why doesn't the announcer tell us
that at some warehouse, you know,
the price today was, uh, and the
reason is that, as I was saying,
those prices are not meaningful because
there they jump around because of reason.
So this is the price. Um, uh,
and so the other thing that I want to
emphasize is that these markets are used
to manage risks of
holding or raising grain.
Most of the time people who are trading
in this market do not complete the
contract. In other words, if I,
let's say I'm a farmer raising corn and
I'm worried that the price of corn might
fall while I'm raising it and I
lose money, right? I'm, you know,
if if the world market
for corn drops, then, uh,
I might not be able to
cover my expenses this year.
And so I could be at great risk so
I can sell in the futures market,
but I probably won't deliver
to the futures market.
And why not?
Because the delivery point is in Chicago
and I'm a farmer in Iowa and I don't
know how to deliver it
all the way to Chicago.
I'd have to rent trucks and
drive to Chicago with my car.
I'm not going to do that. I'm always just
delivering to the local grain elevator.
In fact, I don't have to,
I don't need any trucks.
The guy will pick it up from my farm.
And so, uh, that's what I want to do.
So what I do typically is I
sell in the futures market.
I as a farmer and then one day
before the contract expires,
instead of delivering, I will buy
it back and cancel out my contract.
And then, so all I've done is a
purely financial trade in the future.
You see the difference, I don't actually
want to deliver because it's two truck,
too much trouble to deliver.
So you get farmers trading all over the
country and all over the world in this
market as a way of hedging their corn
and very few of them will ever deliver.
The only reason why delivery is kept
open as an option is that is what sells.
That's what determines the
price in the market. Ultimately,
the only people who deliver
our professional arbitrary
jurors who on the last
day or right when their
contract is expiring,
they look at the futures price
and they say, maybe I can deliver,
maybe I can buy for less than that
and deliver it and I'll really do it.
Those are the only people, so if they
can buy for less than that and deliver,
they'll do it and so they compete with
each other and that brings the futures
price and the spot price in line
at the end. Or alternatively,
if the f the spot price is above
the futures price at the end,
then these arbitragers will
say, hey, I'll take delivery.
I'll go there and I'll take delivery
on a contract and then I'll sell it and
make money.
And it's of the arbitragers that the
cash price and the spot price line up at
the end. It's not through any, um, uh, uh,
law requirement.
And so you see what people are doing.
They're using the futures market
as a purely financial market.
Most people relying on the
arbitrary jurors to, uh,
to,
uh,
enforce the futures prices converging
on the spot price at the end.
Most people are not even raising the
right kind of core maybe or I don't know
how a lot of them certainly are.
There's all different kinds of corn and
if you are raising one kind of corn and
are hedging your risks with
a different kind of corn,
that's called cross hedging. Okay. Uh,
cross pledging.
That means across products.
I'm going from one product to another,
so I could be raising some of this
beautiful Indian corn that remember,
it turns all these different
colors and people put it,
hang it on their doors and Halloween,
um,
that's not suitable for
delivery at the CBOT. Uh,
so if I'm raising that, there's no
market for this, uh, it's no future.
It's no big market for that. But it
probably correlates with regular corn.
So I could cross hedge.
If I'm raising Indian corn and
I'm worried about the price,
I can sell in the futures market in
Chicago and buy it back the next day.
I said I was going to show you
what's in the Wall Street Journal.
I got this this morning from the
Wall Street Journal. That's all.
They have four futures markets in the,
in the newspaper.
Unless I've missed it, I couldn't
find it. Commodities and currencies,
they don't have any agricultural
futures mentioned at all in uh,
Chicago in the Wall Street Journal.
But uh,
as I'm going to talk about next period,
most futures has migrated to financial
futures anyway. It's the same idea,
but it's not agricultural. I don't
see anything agricultural up here. Uh,
there's commodities. There's crude
oil and natural gas. Um, gold.
Everything else is purely financial.
Well,
actually we've got the
DJ Aig Commodity Index.
That's an index of a number of prices,
probably including agricultural.
Uh, and, uh, so that, that's
traded lots of Maura's traded.
I went down to cbot.com this morning
and I got wheat futures prices.
This is a,
well this is on their website and you
don't need any special permission to get
on CBO t.com they're actually changing
the name of the website though.
I think it will be
CME group.com because of their merger
with the Chicago Mercantile Exchange.
So, uh, this is the same thing that
we just saw. Uh, this is the price of,
um, of a Bushel of wheat. Uh, and uh,
so this is, uh, uh,
as of um, uh, would it be last Friday,
932 cents a Bushel?
Uh,
and it ranged from 885 it
caused that it's high nine. No,
it closed it and opened it high.
It's high and it's settled down.
So we went down on the,
and this is for delivery in May of 2008.
And these contracts go out to 2010. This
doesn't show open interest, but, um,
you understand what this is, man. Um,
now the,
the real,
the price that we talk about when we talk
about commodities is the futures price
overwhelmingly. So, uh, the, uh,
this is the Chicago board
of trade price for corn,
um, since 1929 I, we could
take it even further back,
but because he's exchangers,
exchanges have been going since, uh,
the CBOT goes back to the 1860s.
But anyway,
this is the long time horizon,
a plot of the price of corn.
Uh,
and I adjusted it for CPI inflation.
And so this shows,
uh, in dollars per Bushel, of course,
contracts are for 5,000 bushels.
So you'd have to multiply
these numbers by 5,000. Um, so,
uh,
and this just shows what has been
happening to the real price of corn since
1929. There's a lot of
talk recently. It must,
you must have heard it about
this spike up. Uh, in fact,
it's quite a hefty spike up.
It's a doubled more than doubled in real
terms and just the last couple of years.
Do you know why this is?
Why is corn getting expensive right now?
But what's there, right?
It's, that's the theory.
I think it's right that,
uh,
it's because oil prices are
getting high and because, uh,
we can make alternative fuels out of,
um,
food stuffs a cane or corn.
And so in response to the high oil prices,
as also subsidies for ethanol production,
corn is being demanded to run automobiles
a and all these rich people who want
their SUV is they want
to, uh, have a good drive,
are now paying more for
the corn and bidding it up.
And this is a huge international crisis
because it's spreading over all of the
grains. And it's a, it's a
worrisome situation because,
uh,
people in some of the poorest parts of
the world cannot tolerate a doubling of
the price of grain.
Uh, they'll starve. Uh,
and so this is a huge moral issue that
we're facing right now that in order to
keep our cars going, we're driving
some people to starvation. Uh,
on the other hand, uh, I
don't mean to minimize that.
I thought it was interesting to
look at the whole run of, uh,
of corn prices back to 1929 and
they have come down a great deal.
Uh, it's quite curious if
you correct for inflation,
it was like $15 a Bushel in 1950.
On top of that,
our incomes have risen.
And so I think this says
something about why futures,
agricultural futures are not as
prominent as they used to be.
It used to be that food was really a
lot more expensive and a bigger share of
our income.
And we live in a very plenty as time.
This is very unusual by
historical standards right
now you just eat whatever you
want, right? You don't even
look at the price, right?
It's also cheap. Maybe you do,
maybe you don't eat caviar
for because of price. But, uh,
we're just in a time of plenty
with the real price of food so low,
it's not normal times
historically. So, uh,
agricultural futures are
somewhat, uh, downplayed.
But I wanted to give an
example of wheat futures, um,
because, uh, this is, um,
uh, we have a reading on the reading
list by Holbrook working. Uh,
Holbrook working was the great theorist
of futures markets and it's actually,
uh,
read the reading comes from the 1950s
and he is explaining futures market.
I like this,
uh,
article because it sets it forth very
well and nothing has changed since the
1950s except that the
markets are electronic now.
So I wanted to focus in
on one futures market.
And this is the market for wheat and are
these are the standards for delivery at
the Chicago Board of trade. I got this
off their website and this is current.
This is today. Uh, if you,
one contract is 5,000 bushels, okay. Uh,
they will accept a number of different
kinds of wheat that meet there. There,
there must be some standards for quality,
no bugs in it and whatever else.
But Dell except number two,
soft red winter or number two,
hard red winter,
uh, are, uh, what is it?
See, I just copied this from,
there were no nar,
it says no dark northern spring.
Now it must be numbers,
something. What happened?
I must've lost the number two northern
spring and all those are at par.
However, you can also deliver
a number one soft red winter.
That's different cause we, this is number
two, soft red winter or a number one,
hard red winter or number one,
dark northern and not
number one northern spring.
And you get 3 cents a Bushel
over the contract price.
What's they're trying to do is recognize
that there is so many different kinds
of wheat. Um, and so I thought, um,
uh, we would remind
ourselves of um, of what,
uh, they are, uh,
one c hard, uh, hard. It's soft.
Wheat is used for making biscuits and
breast breakfast cereals and cakes and
hard wheat is used for
making bread. Uh, and if you,
if you do baking, you should not
just always use all purpose flour.
You should get the different varieties
and that's what is being mentioned here,
these different varieties.
Um, okay. Now I wanted to,
uh, let me see. Uh,
I wanted to talk about the
Holbrook working paper, uh,
Holbrook working talks about, I'm
sorry, I'm having trouble about,
um, uh, it's, uh, let me,
the difference between winter is
anyone here was a farmer or great,
did anyone grow up on a farm? Can
anyone tell the story of a winter wheat?
Nope. Nobody. We're not very
down to earth people here. Okay.
There's two s two planty.
There's winter wheat and spring wheat,
winter wheat. You plant it in the
winter and you harvested in the spring.
Uh, it stays in the ground all winter
and it comes up the first thing and it's
coming up now and you
harvest winter wheat in May,
so we're almost close to the harvest.
Did you know that there are these way
amber waves of grain flowing in the wind
out there and the wheat belt
right now? Uh, and they're there.
They will soon be harvested in a another
month and a half spring wheat you
planted in the spring and you
harvest it in the fall. Uh,
but they're allowing now
delivery of either one.
When Holbrook working wrote the paper,
there was a separate contract
for hard winter wheat. Uh,
and so I think that there's
some consolidation of these
markets as agricultural
futures is becoming less important.
So that's why we just have,
this is the only cbot wheat
market, uh, that's listed now.
Okay. So, um, you understand
what the contract is.
The contract is to deliver one of
these varieties and there's a separate
contract for each of these dates. Uh, and
okay, so the, what is the
pricing? This is the thing,
what is the futures
price? Uh, now there's,
this is what I'm going
to try to conclude on.
It depends on whether
wheat is in storage or not.
Normally we is in storage because we
only harvest of particular variety once a
year and we have to consume it all
year, right? So after the harvest,
the warehouses get full and then they're,
they're brimming with wheat.
Okay.
And then as the year goes down,
the warehouses deplete their
contents of wheat and it hits zero,
right?
When the new harvest comes in and then
it all gets booked packet back into the
warehouse. This is a
physical necessity. Uh,
when there is wheat in storage,
normally most of the time this relation
should hold the price of the futures
contract should equal the spot price
times one plus the interest rate between
now and delivery.
Uh,
and that is that it means that if say
interest rates are 5% a year and the
delivery is in six months,
then this should be 0.025,
right half of a year. I want to,
it's not annual interest rate,
it's the interest rate until delivery
or if it's a third of a year, you know,
you divide by whatever the,
uh, it's the interest from,
from today until delivery date and s is
the cost of storage from today until the
delivery date.
This should hold normally all the time.
And why is that?
Because if I'm running a
warehouse storing grain,
I'm uh,
I can either sell at the spot price
or I can today I can always unload my
warehouse and sell it today.
Or I can wait and deliver it in
the future at the futures contract.
But at today as a warehouse,
I'm losing money because
of the cost of storage. Uh,
I have to pay insurance and I have
to do other things that are, that,
that maintain the quality of my storage.
And that's s on top of that,
I'm losing an interest because
if I'm storing the grain,
I'm not getting interest on the
money that I paid for that grade.
So that's another loss to me.
So this is the breakeven
for storing grain.
If the future's price is enough above
the spot price that it pays for my
interest cost and my storage costs,
I'm making money storing grain, right?
If,
if the future's price is below this,
I'm not going to store grain.
I'll unload my warehouse.
Why should I store grain
for another minute?
If I'm a professional warehouse offer
and I see that I can make more money by
selling my grain today,
then I will do it. Um,
conversely, if the future's
price is above the spot price,
uh, then I'm going to
want to store more grain.
I'm going to go out and buy up other grain
and that's going to tend to force the
spot price up.
So this relationship to
hold almost all the time,
or you might say it holds all the
time if you interpret it correctly.
Normally the futures price is above the
cash price because interest rates are
positive and storage costs are
positive and it has to be that way.
The normal course of brain of grain
prices over the harvest year is to rise as
the year progresses because
it has to be that way.
The grain is cheapest
right after the harvest,
when there's a lots of green around,
uh,
and then the grain price goes up steadily
throughout the year until the new
harvest comes in and then it
collapses. So it's the, the,
the price of grain over
the year, uh, is, uh,
it's a sawtooth pattern.
Uh,
if there's nothing interfering with it,
the
price of grain,
uh,
we'll tend to look like this.
Okay. And these are the
harvest, right? And,
and the reason that the price of grain
is going up between harvest is to
compensate the warehouse owners.
They're not going to do this business
if they're not getting compensated.
So this is almost like an iron
law. This is going to hold, um,
but it doesn't necessarily home,
uh,
in a given year because there's
other things that affect price.
Uh, so this is what I was saying, that
arbitrage enforces spirit bear valley.
But there is a problem if
there is no grain in storage.
So for example, right at the harvest
end when the harvest is coming in,
the relation between futures and
spot price can become very erratic.
The futures price can be way below
the fair value, the right hand side,
spot times one plus r plus
acids called fair value.
Futures can be below
fair value. Uh, and, and,
and there's no way to for arbitrage
to make up the difference because,
uh, there's nothing if the
future is we're very low, uh,
let me see.
You would want to take money out of,
take grain out of storage and sell
it on the spot price, that market.
But if there isn't whole grain in storage,
you can't do that.
So it sometimes happens when
the grain is not in storage,
that the price of the
future is below fair value.
But there's another interpretation
of it. People would say, well,
but there is still some grain in
storage. It's not gone everywhere. Uh,
so how can it sometimes be that the
futures price is below fair value?
Well, you might say, and
this is, um, that, um,
that the,
you could either say that sometimes
the between price and fair value is
violated, or you could say,
no, it's never violated.
But sometimes the storage
cost is negative. Uh,
and so we have something
called convenience yield,
which has a negative storage costs.
Suppose you are a,
uh,
corn merchant and you're noting that
right now the market is in backwardation.
The futures price is less than the
spot price. So you're thinking,
uh, I want to, I want to
get grain somehow, uh,
and sell it on the spot
market and I'll make money.
So you go around trying to find someone
to sell your grain and you find that
someone has it and won't sell it to
you. And you'd say, well, why not?
Uh, and the guy will say, because I
need this grain, who has green, when,
when the market is in backwardation,
uh, it's somebody who really needs it.
So for example, in the
case of, uh, of wheat,
you might find that you go to the
factor that makes weedies. Okay.
And you say, uh, uh, I,
I'd like to buy your wheat.
Uh, have noting that, uh, uh,
the spot price is really high or
you won't tell him that. I said,
I just want to buy your week, whatever
you've got, I'll buy it at the, uh, um,
uh, at the, uh, and uh,
you shouldn't put it that I guess I'm
saying that was not going to work.
If you do,
why doesn't the weedies manufacturer
sell it's grain on the spot market?
The reason is that they need
we to make weedies. And so,
uh, for them they want to have
some on hand. They might think,
well,
if we didn't have any storage of wheat,
we would be at the mercy of delivery.
And who knows when the harvest is out.
Now we might not be able to get any
wheat and we might have to shut our whole
factory down and tell everyone to take
a day off. That costs us a lot of money.
So you know,
we're,
we really need to have wheat in storage
at the Wheaties factory and so at when
the market is in
backwardation, uh, the, um,
the only grain that stored is, is the, um,
is the grain that's there
for convenience purpose.
So I was just going to go through the
example that Holbrook working gives a in
his reading,
which you have a back then there
was a number two hard winter wheat,
Kansas City, a future maybe there
still is, I don't know, but not CVOT,
but he's, we're going to do
this 1956 or seven story.
Okay. Or here I have it here.
Hard wheat is used for bread,
soft wheat for five. Remember
this? A cooking tip. All right. Uh,
you can buy flour.
I tell you,
I think grocery store and you
can buy cake flour and um,
there are different.
So Holbrook working is just talking
about what happens in a typical year for
winter wheat.
So we're starting out now with
July to July to a typical year.
A spot wheat was a 229 cents a Bushel.
That's the price on July to the
September future is 232 cents a Bushel.
So the difference between the future
and the spot is called the basis, uh,
which is 3 cents a Bushel.
He is another term is a spot premium,
but that would be minus three. But
that's this, just talk about basis.
The basis is the futures
price minus the spot price.
All right. Uh, so this
just a typical story.
So the future's price is
selling for higher as it
should be because between July
and September,
this is winter wheat.
The harvest is recently and
the harvest came in in May.
And so this is when there's a lot in
storage. Uh, and we really should see the,
the futures price above the spot price.
And,
and indeed we do this spot premium is a,
is the profit that, uh, that
is offered to the warehouser.
The Weyerhaeuser looks at this are
the basis the warehouser people in the
warehouse business are always watching
this every day. And there's looking, oh,
a basis of three. And they're thinking,
are we going to make money on that?
Because they have costs,
but this is how much more they can sell
it in the future then then they can sell
it today. And so they're the
comparing the basis with their costs.
They do that all the time in the warehouse
business. Now, September for now,
it's still remembered the harvest was
made. We're not anywhere near the harvest,
uh, here. Um, now we still have a, a base,
but now the basis has gotten smaller.
This is what happens.
So the warehouse operator,
it's starting to feel uncomfortable.
I was doing really well in July.
I had a basis of three.
Now the basis is down to
one. And so, you know,
it's getting kind of iffy for me whether
I can make money, maybe I should sell.
Uh, and so they're always watching these
markets and thinking about that. Um,
uh, I'm sorry, I take that back.
I forgot. This is both the
September future, right?
So,
uh,
the basis should get smaller because we're
getting closer to the expiration date,
right? Because now it's only one month
interest. Well, actually it's even less.
We're almost expiring. Yeah. I,
I wasn't thinking when I first saw that
the basis should shrink to zero as the
time as you approach the
expiration of the contract.
So someone in a warehouse,
uh,
who's worried about the fluctuation in
the grain will sell it the futures market,
uh, and then expect to
get the basis because, uh,
it doesn't matter what
the price of grain does,
the spot and the future is probably should
converge. The basis should go to zero.
And the 3 cents a Bushel is the profit
that they make on the futures trade.
Uh, and so, and it's,
it's riskless for them at the warehouse
because they're hedging the price risk
and that becomes a nice, clean and easy
business. So I'm looking in July too,
to see what are my costs at the warehouse.
And I'm looking at this basis and I think
if I can keep my costs under 3 cents a
Bushel, including interest, uh,
then I will make money because this
basis is going to converge to zero at the
end for sure.
And so are the spot premium.
We'll go from minus three to zero.
So this is a normal month.
Someone's storing grain had this basis
of 3 cents a Bushel and is doing business
as usual, storing for less than
that and making money. And if,
if not less than that, they'd
get out of it. Um, and so, um,
then continuing through the year, um, uh,
now they roll into December futures
because I'm still storing grain that I do
this all year, right? I'm
trading in the, in the,
the nearest month contract because that's
where the open interest is and that's
where all the trading is.
And so as soon as the, uh,
September contract expires,
I don't actually want to deliver.
I'll sell out and I'll make the profit,
which is the change in basis.
Now when it comes to, uh,
and now September four,
I've made that profit of 2 cents a Bushel.
The difference between the 3 cents
a Bushel basis and the one sentence.
And now I start a new contract to
now because September is expiring,
I move in, I rolled over into
the December contract, uh,
and I'm just going to do this
every con every three months, uh,
I'm going to roll over into the
next contract. So in this case,
I didn't put the basis, the basis was
five and three quarters cents a Bushel.
So now it's looking even
better here in September,
I'm had jumps around the basis,
jumps around with market conditions,
but it's looking good now because I
have a basis of five and three quarters
since.
And so I'll buy,
I'll sell my grain again on a futures
contract and then I will close it out.
December when the, and this is
December one now. Now the price of, of,
of, of wheat has gone up a
lot from two 38 to two 52.
But you know, it's not going to be a
profit for me. I, I'm not, I'm, I'm,
I hedged it, but I'll make the, for me,
the profit is the change
in the spot premium.
So I made five and three quarters
cents a Bushel minus my cost,
and then I'll just stop.
[inaudible] I'm running out of time.
What happens at harvest? I'm doing
this all year. Finally on May,
this is the new harvest is coming
in. And look what happens. Now,
this market is suddenly,
uh,
in backwardation now look what's happening
in the Spock premium is 18 cents a
Bushel. The basis is minus
18. If I hold on, if I,
if I roll into July futures and hold on,
I'm going to lose really big time.
So I'm out, I'm out of the business.
We sell off everything in
the warehouse and we're done.
So this is the process
by which warehousing is
optimized and we get drained
smoothly through the year,
but it's a basic principle that
we'll see in the next lecture, uh,
extends as well to other,
um, other kinds of, uh,
financial futures.
So next period we're going to
talk about other kinds of futures,
uh,
including financial futures.